( intro music )
Most people, when you
say Arabia, they think
camels, terrorism,
pirates?
Oil and gas.
They don't think
coral reefs.
Or sharks.
So, I proposed a story to
National Geographic magazine
to kind of change that.
You know, 'cause Arabia
is home to some of the most
incredible marine
ecosystems on our planet.
You know, fortunately
the story was approved
and off I went.
And at the same time as
the Arab Spring was going on.
So, my timing on these
stories is not ideal.
But, nonetheless, you know,
the Arabian Peninsula
and we covered parts of
the African coast as well
the Red Sea, the Gulf of Aden,
the Arabian Sea and
then the Persian Gulf.
We began in the Gulf of Aden
on the Somali-Djibouti border.
Sandwiched between pirates and
the Western Naval forces
hunting the pirates
there is an aggregation
of whale sharks.
Which nobody knows
about and every year
these young, juvenile
whale sharks
aggregate to feed.
Whale sharks have finger
prints, just like us.
And you can identify them
by looking at the
spot pattern on them.
And each whale shark
is completely unique
with the spot pattern.
So, after a week or two, I think
there was almost more than
a 100 different whale sharks
feeding in that larger area.
The biggest danger for
a photographer here
is becoming a whale
shark's sandwich.
And then you get this sort of
you know, these guys
actually suck the water in.
It's an incredible stationary
feeding-gulping behavior.
I also spent a lot of time
with the local
Somali Afari fishermen.
'Cause I wanted
to document their
relationship with the ocean.
I spent many nights
out at sea with them
and then one night after
midnight, they go
"Hey, you know,
we sometimes have
lots of whale sharks
around our boat at night."
And I go, "Whale sharks
don't feed at night."
They go, "Yes, they do."
These guys have these sort
of lights on their boats
and with those lights they
attract small plankton
which attracts bait fish.
And they catch these
bait fish with nets.
And then they use
the bait to catch
on a hook to catch larger fish.
And the whale sharks love
the free meal of plankton.
And they rub up against
the boats and I'm going
"I have to take this picture."
No one had actually
documented this before.
So, I go in the water and
I'm using my flashes
and they ruin the complete
night time ambience.
And the whale sharks
don't like it.
And then I shoot without them
but the lights on these boats
are just way, way too dim.
You know, luckily,
I come prepared.
And you know, at night, you
know, we park the big boat
next to the small fishing boats
and we turn on the light.
And the light attracts
little plankton
which attracts big plankton
which attracts little fish,
which attracts bigger fish.
And then after an hour
or two it attracted
the world's biggest fish.
It's kind of weird because
it's hard to, you know
get a perspective of
size with whale sharks.
But these are
actually juveniles.
This is an aggregation
of sub-adults.
Now at first I was disappointed.
"Oh, they are just
small whale sharks
just a hundred of them.
That sucks.
I wish they were bigger."
( audience laughter )
When I was taking the images,
having them small actually
made all the difference.
Because you know,
you're under water,
all you have is this
very thin cone of light
and you're in the dark
and all you can see is
these whale sharks moving
in and out of the light
like ships, you know, looming
in and out of the fog.
And then you get pictures like
this.
You know, just kinda just
coming out of the gloom.
But I really wanted a
picture of the whale shark
more interacting with the light.
I did this for day after
day and at the end I got
this frame.
( audience captivated )
You know, the whale shark was
vertically suction feeding
for about half an hour
in that position.
So, this was, you know, anybody
could have taken that picture
because he stood
there for that long.
( audience laughter )
Not much to point and shoot,
not much skill to bear.
But with a larger whale shark
I would have gotten a
fin or half a head.
So, it's only 'cause these
guys are juveniles.
That is the only reason I was
able to get this picture.
You know, from the Gulf
of Aden, Saudi Arabia.
You know, my interest
was mainly up on the
Iraq-Iran-Kuwait border.
My mother despairs.
Every time she finds out
where my next assignment is.
And, of course, armed guards
wherever I went, you know.
And, this is a world of mud.
Mud, mud and more mud.
And we had to use a hovercraft.
Star Wars, right?
I mean, come on!
In a hovercraft, it was
just like the crazy...
And why did I go there?
Well, I wanted to photograph
the animal that made these.
Now these are very,
very tiny mud walls.
But, in a desert environment
like this, they are life savers.
Because basically
they retain water.
And the animal that made them
are mud skippers.
( audience gasps )
Not your normal garden
variety mudskipper.
Arabian mudskippers.
That big and this thick.
And they do these incredible
courtship displays.
They leap as high as they can
whichever male leaps the highest
gets the female, I think.
They also have these
cool fighting displays.
( audience surprised )
They puff each other up and
they raise the dorsal
and then they just stare at
each other and they do all
these sort of...
You know for these pictures,
you lie in the mud for an hour
before these fish
come out of the hole.
So, you are stationary
for days to get
you know, these little glimpses.
But, yeah, I love these guys.
Like, "Oy!"
You can hear him
screaming right?
"That's my female mudskipper,
or whatever."
( audience laughter )
Anyway, let's move on.
You know, I moved on to
turtles on the Arabian Sea.
And as I was shooting all
this great bio-diversity
I'm going, "Hang on, I'm
not seeing any sharks."
After the whale sharks, I hadn't
seen a single other shark.
I'm like, what's going on here.
And I figured it out when
I was you know, in Oman,
photographing seasonal
kelp forest communities
at Salalah.
And one evening I was in this
little place called Mirbat.
It's this place that
kind of time forgot.
It's this sort of old school
Arab fishing village.
And there's this wall
of people at the port.
And I kind of, you know gently
elbow my way through, you know.
And as the crowd parts
I see this.
( audience sighing )
This is about 93 silky sharks.
This is one boat's load.
And every hour
another boat arrives
and offloads exactly the
same number of sharks.
So, the one night I was there
I think there must've
been a 1,000 silky sharks.
And then they auction
everything off.
And at the end of the auction
all the sharks are loaded
into these freezer trucks.
And they're taken away.
And I wanted to know where
so I started following
these trucks.
I ended up in these ice-houses.
Now these trucks are
not freezer trucks.
They are insulated but
they are badly insulated.
So, every, you know,
few hundred kilometres
they have to restock with ice.
And that's where they
kind of, you know
barter the sharks
and resell them.
And there I found out,
and an actual fact
all these sharks are going
to Dubai. So...
I went to Dubai.
And there I saw, you know
dozens of Omani
trucks offloading
large Arabian Sea sharks.
And you know, fins are
only cut off there.
And the meat goes to
Bangladesh, goes to Pakistan,
it goes to Sri Lanka
for consumption.
It's the cheapest sort of
meat protein there is.
And the fins are
exported to Asia
for royal sums and
princely sums.
And it appears that, over
the last couple of years
Dubai has become the
fourth largest exporter
of shark fins to
Hong Kong in the world.
And that is, you know, had
really sort of bypassed
most of the scientific
literature that I had reviewed.
So, this was a massive surprise
to actually be able to
document this trade route across
the great Arabian Desert.
And, you know, went to
Hong Kong afterwards
and I tried to track these
fins all the way to Hong Kong.
There's a street in Hong Kong
that basically is dedicated only
to shark fin and dried seafood.
I think it was 140 different
shops, you know, Shark Fin City.
And that's where I found
my sharks, dried in shops.
You know the article
was published 2012.
A lot of conservation issues
were addressed in it and
you know, it kind
of really began
a conversation in the
Middle East as well about
how to better manage
shark fisheries.